this video is brought to you by mubi get
30 days of movie for free when you go to
mubi.com thomasflight
one of my favorite techniques in nope is
about to happen right here
did you catch that listen again
was that the wind
or maybe something else
if you've seen the movie you know the
answer but the first time you watched it
you probably didn't know what you were
hearing or if you were hearing anything
out of the ordinary at all
for me the most unsettling moment in
nope was this one a long tracking shot
that doesn't really show you anything a
big part of why this moment is so
effective is because it creates Terror
instead of Horror
at the start of every Jordan peel movie
you'll see a title card for his
production company
said Mrs White curiously the name of the
company monkey paw Productions is a
reference to a short story by w w Jacobs
hold it up in your right hand and wish
aloud said the sergeant major
but I warn you of the consequences
in this story when an old man and his
family are visited by a mysterious
traveler he receives a magical dried
monkey paw that can grant three wishes
the old man hoping to better the
financial situation of his family ask
for the sum of 200 pounds with his first
wish the old man and his family expect
the money to fall out of the sky or
appear under his pillow when that
doesn't happen they suspect the Paw may
be a hoax but the next day the old man
and his wife receive another visitor
telling them that their son died
tragically in an accident at work and he
gives them compensation of 200 pounds
fulfilling the first wish they're struck
with grief and after burying their son
they have an idea the old man uses the
Paw again his second wish that his son
would be alive again
they wait for hours and nothing happens
but after night falls they're awoken by
a knocking at the door the old man now
reminded of the Twisted nature of the
granting of the first wish is terrified
of what might be on the other side of
that door
and in an act of desperation before his
wife can answer the door he grabs the
Paw and uses his third wish to wish
whatever is on the other side of that
door
would disappear
when they open the door nothing is there
it's a gripping story but the Brilliance
of it is that as readers we never
actually see anything horrifying the
author leaves it to our imagination and
leaves the actual existence of the
horror ambiguous film writer Matthew
Morgan in an essay about what this story
can tell us about the distinction
between horror and Terror puts it this
way this is the essence of Terror it is
the gut deep dread of the awful
possibilities Horror by contrast is what
we'd have if the story allowed the door
to be opened before the final wish could
be made to reveal whatever monster stood
there
Jordan Peele understands this dynamic
between horror and Terror and utilizes
it frequently in nope in the Gordy's
house scenes he expertly holds back and
obscures the horror of the scene instead
allowing our imagination to do the work
inspiring Terror
[Music]
Spielberg does the same thing in this
sequence from the opening of Jaws where
he frames out the Carnage that we all
know is present hiding it instead of
showing it builds anticipation for what
might be shown and leaves a question in
the viewer's mind about the true nature
of the horror we're not seeing
I want to show how these ideas ambiguity
our imagination and the distinction
between Terror and horror can play out
within the sound design of a film
[Applause]
one of jaw's most tense scenes is early
on we know there's been a shark attack
but the beaches haven't been closed so
Chief Brody sits on the beach watching
and waiting and crucially so does the
audience there's a lot that Spielberg is
doing here to build suspense and
anticipation but one of the most clever
things he does is use visual ambiguity
for example This Woman's feet look a
little bit like a shark fin and this
splashing looks like it could be a shark
attack when the film is quickly cutting
back and forth between the ocean and
Brody scanning the water tensely for
signs of a shark these little visually
ambiguous elements momentarily trick us
into thinking we might be seeing a shark
or an attack but you can create
ambiguity and sound as well Spielberg
does this in this scene with the screen
it turns out to just be someone having
fun but for a split second we might
think they're screams of Terror
foreign
[Music]
peel and his sound designer Johnny Burns
took advantage of Sonic ambiguity to
design the sound of the UFO for nope
our ears have a difficult time
distinguishing between two sounds that
overlap within certain frequencies
and they used this fact to their
advantage by designing a sound for the
UFO they used animal screams and morphed
bird sounds Blended seamlessly with
sounds of wind
they gave the sound of the UFO an
ambiguous quality where you're not quite
sure what you're hearing exactly
especially in those early scenes
let's go
In This Moment like in the scene on the
beach from Jaws we know there's already
been an attack and we're waiting for
something and among all the other sounds
of the night we're hearing the wind but
there's a little something else in there
too it's hard to figure out what that
might be because the sound team keeps
using other sounds like the horses snort
here
to overlap the other element a little
bit it's like the Sonic equivalent of
the door desk and tablecloth that are
shrouding our view of the horror in this
shot and after the tension builds for a
while in this scene we get this sound
a big ambiguous thud that ends up being
benign it's like the Sonic version of
the visual ambiguity of this splashing
in Jaws
all this ambiguity and uncertainty
around the sound of the UFO creates
anticipation and Terror and it creates
an unsettling reveal as the movie
progresses when you slowly start to put
together the fact that what you're
hearing isn't the wind or even some kind
of crazy UFO screeching but actually
screams of the UFO's victims
foreign
listen to this
[Applause]
how can you tell these aren't screams of
horror often the line between a scream
of Joy or pleasure and horror is a fine
one and like in this case we might rely
on context clues to help figure it out
if we hear the sound of a roller coaster
in the background we assume that the
screams are screams of people having fun
or at least the screams of people who
aren't imminently in danger
when designing the sound of what happens
when people get sucked up into the UFO
they ask the group of actors who
recorded these sounds to scream like
they were on a roller coaster and then
asked them to scream like well they were
getting digested by a giant UFO then
they Blended those two together and the
result what we hear in nope is pretty
unsettling
add in the bizarre robbery grating sound
you get by rubbing the windscreen of a
lavalier microphone
you have Sonic horror this mixture which
adds ambiguity to the sound also plays
to the themes of the film I talked about
in my last video on nope it makes a lot
of sense for a movie that's commenting
on how the lines between entertainment
and real trauma get blurred Sonic
ambiguity is pervasive throughout nope
seen in the barn were unsure what sounds
are being generated by the sprinkler and
what sounds are being generated by the
aliens
Jordan Peele chose his sound designer
Johnny Burns based on his work in
Jonathan Glazer's sci-fi horror Under
the Skin a movie about a predatory alien
that stays away from otherworldly sound
design and instead uses a naturalistic
soundscape to create tension and
atmosphere
nope uses a similar approach for a movie
about a UFO there's very little
otherworldly sound instead the
soundscape is mostly naturalistic and
domestic just modified slightly to sound
a little out of place consider the sort
of generic banging clunking sound used
in the Gordy's home scenes that opens
the film it's more unsettling precisely
because it's so mundane isolated it
could just be someone banging their shoe
on the floor but given the context we
fear and imagine it could be something
so much worse but ambiguity and
uncertainty aren't the only way sound
can create the engagement necessary for
an engrossing horror film we do use
focal points sometimes too
guide someone into a state of heightened
suggestibility height and suggestibility
that's right
right that's right
let's go back to Jaws for a moment if
you think of Jaws and sound you probably
think of this
but there's another element of jaw sound
that I think plays just as big a role as
the score does in making these moments
impactful
and it's the Calm before the storm
in this scene we talked about earlier as
we're introduced to the beach there's a
rich natural soundscape we hear the
radio we hear people talking but as the
tension mounts and Brody scans the water
listen to what happens to that
soundscape
every day there are hundreds or
thousands of sounds in our environment
that we ignore or tune out but I'm sure
you remember moments in your own life
where you suddenly became aware of the
Sounds in your environment these moments
of heightened awareness are usually
are usually due to fear anxiety or being
in an unfamiliar situation our alertness
to The Sounds in our environment becomes
heightened when we're listening for what
we think might be Danger
this means that for horror and suspense
filmmakers who are trying to place
viewers in a heightened state of
anticipation or fear the background
soundscape of a film can play a unique
role in a scene where the focus is what
people are saying they'll avoid
distracting sounds like this one
the gentle bubbling of a coffee pot
because it's not important information
for the scene and if we were having a
day-to-day conversation in our real
lives with the coffee pot bubbling in
the background our brain would tune it
out but in A Moment Like This the lack
of meaning in the sound is important
these sounds give our anxious ears
something to scan for potential danger
and they allow our imaginations to run
wild wondering what the sound might be
or what might be hiding behind it
and then when we're carefully scanning
the environment for sounds of danger as
the viewer
unnatural silence can be just as
important a tool in building
anticipation
listen to this moment from nope if I
highlight just the background sound of
the scene
you can hear how all of a sudden it
falls away into a very unnatural quiet
this creates a calm before the storm
sort of Effect one that's barely
perceivable but one that affects your
perception of the scene nonetheless
it's the score and the shark attack aka
the horror that audiences tend to
remember but it's the soft clanging of
the buoy that creates the necessary
Terror for that horror to hit home
mubi is a curated streaming service
where you can watch beautiful
exceptional interesting Cinema everyday
mubi premieres a new film when they hand
pick from Iconic directors or emerging
auteurs my favorite thing about mubi is
how intentional the library is
everything is there because someone felt
it should be I also want to tell you
about mubi's new print magazine notebook
it's published biannually if you
subscribe you'll get two issues every
year it's truly a beautiful publication
that focuses on the art and culture of
Cinema in the first issue I especially
enjoyed Patrick haldol's article it's
impossible to film a garden if you're
not a gardener they are pieces of Art in
and of themselves and each issue will
come with a special exclusive gift for
magazine subscribers subscribe to
notebook using the link in the
description below and get 30 days of
movie for free by going to mubi.com
thomasflight
[Music]
thank you
[Music]